you got a long career ahead of you bro I
do that's what everybody says I got a
never mind I was going to say joke no
you no you really do have a long career
ahead of you bro like yeah I hope so man
I really do I really do just you nobody
wants to see anybody like you know the
the whole thing you know I don't want to
see you crash out you know what I'm
saying or or get yourself into a
situation where no I'm going to be hot
forever that's my biggest dream that's
my biggest downfall I get what you're
saying is to have not be hot and ruin my
career over one thing and it could
happen it can happen at any time don't
take it for granted yeah um and if it
happens it happens F [__] it [__] it hey
[__] it I'm still going to keep rapping
nah bro you got a long career ahead of
you you're just getting started and the
other thing is like you like you could
really like bar out you know what I'm
saying like you really could rap rap for
real for real like yeah you know what
I'm I'm very impressed by your your your
skill level you know what I'm going say
like this do like hey dog I Get High dog
like I do drink every day like I'm
[__] in the hood every day I don't
give a [__] fool I'm in the hood every
day like fools don't understand like
what the [__] I'm going through and if
you do cool if you talk [__] cool I
still got more money than you cool I'm
still better than you I still got two
banjos you can't be happy for me I'm
happy for anybody doing it I don't even
know what the [__] I'm saying right now
I'm just saying like so what I'm drunk
I'm high I don't give a [__] I look at
all the comments and they always say the
same [__] like like what man oh he's
high whatever like man you sound like a
cop every comment like parole officer
like I'm high so what my mom knows I'm
high everybody knows I'm high they told
me to stop I ain't going to stop I'll
stop you know when when I when I stop
what is your uh your drug of choice all
kind of [__] just everything all kinds
of [__] all kinds of things like I don't
give a [__] like I'm trying catching up
to everybody I'm young for the for
camera purposes marijuana right hell no
that's sh that right now I'm on
marijuana that's why I'm talking this
[__] weed is great I don't even I think
we should edit this weed [__] just
gets me like weed gets me like this fool
just dumb and weed gets me thinking fool
I'm thinking on this [__] now I got to
get off this [__] I told you give me off
here let me go bounce and go do a
[__] fre go yeah yeah Frey go
do a little walk do that all right yo
hey but I give him the best interview I
think I give you a really good interview
I agree brother you're going to edit it
right here and we'll wrap it up at the
end I appreciate you I think he's like
looking at me like [__] Lefty shut the
[__] up like on the game he is embra I'm
trying to you out do he ain't going put
in you
don't man okay but tell Cam too hey
Lefty he don't mean no harm that's how
right you're good like this for sure he
no you're good brother hey man I think
you're dope I think the music is dope I
think uh oh don't get this on camera I'm
looking like I'm stressed
out I hope you cut it right there I only
want to take a swig and get it please
don't post that you going to ruin my
[__] I'll give you all this not to post
that
look now just posting
hey
damn I'm going to put this one away D
I'm [__] ripping it you know why cuz
I went to the strip club right when my
[__] is a stripper right and she had a
bunch of ones right in her purse but I
got a lot of money too you got pay three
bands for RSE in New Mexico blew it all
in two days look I got money too I got
money too right so she's right there and
she's just like I'm like hey I'll trade
you 100 for this H 100 I'll trade you
100 for this H 100 I'll trade you 100
for this H 100 just cuz I like the way
it looks it just looks like more just to
talk come out with a brick now I'm
looking at it cuz I put the 50s in the
front pull that out my pocket trying to
make a joke out of it listen and it
ripped and it's ripping so now I'm like
putting the 50s back right now and I'm
going to put them away and stop showing
off what is it I don't give a [__] it's
like what
$1,000 hold on let me see how much it is
I don't care I'm not streaming showing
off I don't even care if we're recording
200 looks like you had a nice night at
the strip club from what I can tell
400 these are leftovers yeah these are
leftovers this is what the girls didn't
get off
you look 50 look hold on window 60 70 80
90 100 100 200 300 400 500 we're doing
banking no wait up no I want to see see
how much I got there 20 30 40 50 60 70
80 90 100 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 100 20
30 40 50 50 60 70 80 90 100 5 10 15 20
21 22 23 24 25 so look I got 100 200 300
400 500 600 700 $800 $825 in my pocket
that's $25 left let's go
baby at least the at least the the young
ladies didn't get all the money off of
you no at the strip club last night
noell there's still leftovers for
tonight I'm the in I'm the in but if I'm
we just got to take you to Tijana with
that I'm not going to lie no I want I'll
spend it in the community this community
dig it's for everybody recreational use
I I I I got to throw back get back to
the community right I'm going go to the
strip clubs in the hood yeah for sure
right I support the ones in the hood got
to support the home girls what I say I
got I got to get you I got to get you
hooked up with some blue Chu $825 what
is that I want some it sounds like it's
a dick pill oh shoot son I got you Blue
CH promo code bootleg you get a free
month tell them let promote it if it's
good it's much better than a Rhino gas
station dick pill you make a brand B oh
yeah we'll get you hooked up on the blue
Cho they'll have you [__] rocked up
bro endorsement deal endorsement deal
for all the sgv strippers bro they
you'll be [__] serving dick like Jack
in the Box tacos at 2: a.m. bro I can't
lie if I say like every time I [__] I
don't [__] pop a rhino everybody the
honey pack I do a rhino sometimes it
[__] me up though like might as well get
red when my question you is is it either
or or do you prefer one over the other
you prefer it's in your head yeah yeah
sometimes like it's in your head like
sometimes I just wing it without it f
have you ever popped a rhino thinking
you were going to [__] but then didn't
and then you ended up beating off at
night and your dick just won't go away
hell no nah
never that happened hell
no hell like I was talking to Ruchi once
and he was like we're talking about show
your DM all the [__] Cas show my DM
yeah show my Lo and lo in press clear
all and press open my DM in front of the
camera cash don't open it n j shoot it
cash no I'm not going to show no I just
want to show these Foods how my DM is
look check it out you you edit them so
when I open it is it going to open on my
page watch I'm going to show you right
now look hold on we're going to go like
this I'm going to go Instagram look here
here's Instagram look okay we're looking
here's my Instagram show the camera show
the camera I'm going like this how do I
do it on iPhone I'm going to go like
this look I'm boom boom bo boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom hey how
much am I making on YouTube Studio cash
hold on just show theck how much am I
making while I'm looking for it okay
here we going okay see 100 100 100 I see
it look
[Music]
Mar that's the camera is this camera H H
hyy honey honey honey hone y h h 100
every time they're all Huns look they're
all Huns mostly women or mostly people
trying to buy verses all types of [__]
like show them the DM show them the DM
cuz like are you you got to be killing
it right now off gu versus I ate to
hitting me up and you're famous I don't
even look at it f spy I don't give a
[__] yeah [__] rap I got money like show
show the [__] in your DM look hun H
hun again I got another one see you
should go through and see what famous
people have hit you up maybe you're
you're missing out on a nice feature
right now hell no no hell no hell no hey
hell hey my bad I'm just kicking the
thing we kicking this still hell no hey
look I'm definitely one of the top five
artists in the SUV shout outs Lefty
Gunplay I appreciate you gang who's this
talking is this the homie OJ the sickest
sick I'm the best uh yeah shout out uh
oh yeah let me let me see it let me see
oh yeah o got an interview that's right
look here's my DM look at my [__] okay
oh man wait let me see who I got in here
let's
see we better hey we better have some
girls in here look let me see wait up
boom bo bo see it all fat wo That's my
boy right there oh look at this [__]
right here that [__] look bad yeah yeah
lot of women [__] that [__] already
there you go I [__] her too look at
Ley hit me up wait up the Jun g ladin
bcv hit me up look Food Network look
okay artist connect Pon Foods wait up
wait up let me see oh let me see it's
lit in there n let me see one
more [__] I I I see the girls I mean
I ain't seeing the messages but I see
you got a bunch of hoes in your [__]
this one stupid young hit me up on a set
stupid young hit you up edited that [__]
though shout out for running let's run
it right now look stupid young shout out
stupid young what it say stupid young
huh yeah that's the homie come on F
shout to Long Beach hey fool I don't
want don't open it yet cuz I want to
read my and answer I want to I want to
read it myself and answer hey I got 925
I dropped 100 on the floor I'm the
winner okay we're going to take this
$925 and go somewhere hell no but look I
appreciate you pulling up we're going to
have You Freestyle is that cool and a
separate video we'll take a little pause
right now no we can do it right now no
no we're going to take a little
break but hey when is Rookie of the Year
coming hey stupid young hit me up F fly
cripping with that thing with
me got get stupid young
my brother and if you SL me you know I'm
going even fool told me you been
tripping for no reason not he bring that
pain song Mando I love stupid young he's
hard super hard that's that's my dream
I'm just living you my dream dog yeah
that's crazy huh hey man stupid young
hit me up I think that's dope I think
you got a bright future ahead lefty gun
playay [__] on the [__] on the
set I'm I'm really the essay stupid
Young D that's crazy I'm bless see
I would have never expected that
[__] is paying for that [__]
like I'm just doing it with him because
he does it for the music I believe like
me he's just like a real hitter like me
anyways I'm going dog well listen
brother I appreciate you we're going to
get the new album soon do we have any
idea when rookie of the year is coming
[__] I hope tonight ohing it sometime in
February it's already sometime in
February it's already done it's already
done sometime in February New
York okay they could have it for a band
right now I appreciate you pulling up
brother yes sir there it is can you
believe I have 925 I can't believe I
dropped 100 on the floor hey man come on
man back 100 baby [__] with you